bien maintenant
Didier Deschamps
je vais jouer avec la Juve vous avez été
entendu par un juge d'instruction
turinois pour des problèmes de d'usage
de dopage disons de créatine qu'en
est-il exactement
j'ai été confronté trois fois oui c'est
vrai injuste d'instruction qui qui avant
même
de poser des questions étaient persuadé
que
il y avait du dopage dans le football
qu'on utilisait le PO donc c'est très
difficile de de faire face à un tel
personnage la créatine aussi c'est vrai
qu'elle est utilisée l'autoriser dans
certains pays dans d'autres non j'en ai
pris pendant une certaine période après
j'ai arrêté je pense pas que ça soit un
produit nocif même si certains
spécialistes le disent mais le dopage en
règle générale et je pense qu'il y en a
dans le sport dans le football j'ai pas
été confronté parce que je pense
sincèrement je vois pas l'utilité je
crois pas que le dopage un produit peut
d'un d'un joueur bidon on peut faire un
super joueur ça jamais fait tirer dans
les lucarnes donc je vois pas trop
l'utilité ça peut faire courir plus vite
ça peut être plus résistant mais il y a
le ballon et le ballon c'est les pieds
il faut savoir le diriger donc les
matchs très souvent même temps donc la
répétition évidemment qu'on a des des
aides au niveau pharmaceutique pour
aider à récupérer mais ce juge là il
partait du principe moi c'est ce qui m'a
dit en fin de d'interrogatoire il me dit
je voudrais arriver à faire une loi que
le footballeur s'y prend un produit une
vitamine C peu importe où on est enrhumé
ou qui prend quelque chose la semaine
avant le match ils ne puisse pas jouer
au match il y aurait plus beaucoup de
football à la télé sincèrement merci de
votre sincérité d'une émission et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de inarritube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu